[MUSIC PLAYING]
DANIEL SITUNAYAKE:
Hey, everybody.
So my name's Daniel.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And I'm Lawrence.
DANIEL SITUNAYAKE: And
we have an awesome talk
for you, this afternoon.
So I've been super
excited watching
the keynote, because there's
just been so much stuff
that is relevant
to what we're going
to be talking about today,
which is running machine
learning on devices.
So we've seen the
kind of amazing things
that you can do if you're
running ML at the edge
and on device.
But there are a ton of
options that developers have
for doing this type of stuff.
And it can be a little
bit hard to navigate.
So we decided to put
this session together
to give you an overview.
We're going to be showing
you all the options,
walking you through some
code, and showing you
some awesome demos.
So hopefully, you'll enjoy.
So first, we're going to
walk through using TensorFlow
to train models and then
export saved models, which
you can then convert
to deploy on devices.
We're then going to see a
number of different ways
that you can deploy to
Android and iOS devices.
And finally, we're
going to talk about
some new and super exciting
hardware devices that you
can use to run your models.
So first of all,
I want to give you
an overview of some different
technologies and the device
types they each
allow you to support.
So to begin with,
we have ML Kit,
which is designed to make
it super easy to deploy
ML inside of mobile apps.
We then have TensorFlow.js,
which basically
lets you target any device that
has a JavaScript interpreter,
whether that's in browser
or through Node.js.
So that even supports
embedded platforms.
And finally, TensorFlow
Lite gives you
high performance inference
across any device or embedded
platform, all the way
from mobile phones
to microcontrollers.
So before we get
any further, let's
talk a little bit about
TensorFlow itself.
So TensorFlow is Google's tool
chain for absolutely everything
to do with machine learning.
And as you can see, there
are TensorFlow tools
for basically every
part of the ML workflow,
from loading data through
to building models
and then deploying them
to devices and servers.
So for this section
of the talk, we're
going to focus on building
a model with TensorFlow
and then deploying it as
a TensorFlow Lite model.
There are actually
tons of ways to get up
and running with
TensorFlow on device.
So the quickest way is to try
out our demo apps and sample
code.
And we also have a big
library of pretrained models
that you can drop into your
apps that are ready to use.
You can also take
these and retrain them
based on your own data
using transfer learning.
You can, as you've
seen this morning,
use Federated Learning
to train models
based on distributed data
across a pool of devices.
And you can finally build
models from scratch,
which is what Laurence
is now going to show off.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Thank you, Daniel.
Quick question for everybody.
How many of you have ever
built a machine learn model?
Oh, wow.
DANIEL SITUNAYAKE: Wow.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, wow.
Big round of applause.
So hopefully, this
isn't too basic for you,
what I'm going to be showing.
But I want to show
just the process
of building a model
and some of the stops
that you can then do
to prepare that model
to run on the mobile devices
that Daniel was talking about.
Can we switch to
the laptop, please?
Can folks at the
back read that code?
Just wave your hands if you can.
OK, good.
Wave them like this
if you need it bigger.
OK, some do, or you
just want to stretch.
Let's see.
How's that?
OK, cool.
So I'm just going to show
some very basic TensorFlow
code, here.
And I wanted to
show the simplest
possible neural
network that I could.
So for those of you who've
never built something in machine
learning or have never
built a machine learn model,
the idea is like with
a neural network,
you can do some basic
pattern matching
from inputs to outputs.
We're at Google
I/O, so I'm going
to talk about inputs
and outputs a lot.
And in this case, I'm
creating the simplest
possible neural network I can.
And this is a neural
network with a single layer
and a single neuron in
that neural network.
And that's this line
of code, right here.
The Keras.layers.Dense
units equal 1.
Input shape equals 1.
And I'm going to then train this
neural network on some data,
and that's what you
can see in the line
underneath-- the Xs and the Ys.
Now, there is a relationship
between these data points.
Can anybody guess what
that relationship is?
There's a clue in the 0 and 32.
AUDIENCE: Temperature.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah, a
temperature conversion, right?
So the idea is I could write
code that's like 9 over 5
plus whatever, plus 32.
But I want to do it as a
machine learn model, just
to give as an example.
So in this case, I'm going
to create this model.
And with this model,
I'm just training it
with six pairs of data.
And then what it will
do is it will start then
trying to infer the relationship
between these data points.
And then from that,
going forward,
it's a super simple model to
be able to do a temperature
conversion.
So how it's going to work is
it's going to make a guess.
And this is how machine
learning actually works.
It just makes a wild guess
as to what the relationship
between these data is.
And then it's got something
called a loss function.
And what that loss
function is going to do
is it's going to see how good or
how bad that guess actually is.
And then based on the
data from the guess
and the data from
the loss function,
it then has an
optimizer, which is this.
And what the optimizer does
is it creates another guess,
and then it will measure
that guess to see how well
or how badly it did.
It will create another guess,
and it will measure that,
and so on, and so on,
until I ask it to stop
or until it does it 500 times,
which is what this line of code
is actually doing.
So if I'm going to create
this model quite simply,
we'll see it's going to train.
There was one that
I created earlier,
so my workbook's taking
a moment to get running.
My network
connection's gone down.
Hang on.
Let me refresh and reload.
You love it when you dry run
a demo, and it works great.
We get that warning.
I'll run that.
I'll do that.
And now, it starts
training, hopefully.
There we go.
It's starting to train, now.
It's going through
all these epochs.
So it's going to
do that 500 times.
And then at the end
of the 500 times,
it's going to have
this trained model.
And then this trained
model, I'm just
going to ask it to predict.
So for example, if I give
it 100 degrees centigrade,
what's that going
to be in Fahrenheit?
The real answer is
212, but it's going
to give me 211 and
something, because this
isn't very accurate.
Because I've only trained
it on six points of data.
So if you think about it,
there's a linear relationship
between the data from Fahrenheit
to centigrade on those six,
but the computer
doesn't know that.
It doesn't go linearly forever.
It could go like this,
or it could change.
So it's giving me a
very high probability
that for 100 degrees centigrade,
it would be 212 Fahrenheit.
And that comes out as
211 degrees centigrade.
So I've just built a model.
And what we're going
to take a look at next
is, how do I get that
model to work on mobile?
Can we switch back to
the slides, please?
So the process is pretty simple.
The idea is like
using Keras or using
an estimator in TensorFlow.
You build a model.
You then save that model
out in a file format
called SavedModel.
And in TensorFlow 2, we're
standardizing on that file
format to make it easier for
us to be able to go across
different types of
runtimes, like JavaScript,
TFX in the web, or
TensorFlow Lite.
By the way, the QR code on
this slide is to the workbook
that I just showed a moment ago.
So if you want to experiment
with that workbook
for yourself, if you're just
learning, please go ahead
and do so.
It's a public URL, so feel
free to have fun with it.
And I put a whole
bunch of QR codes
in the rest of the slides.
Now, once you've done
that, in TensorFlow Lite,
there's something called the
TensorFlow Lite Converter.
And that will convert
our SavedModel
into a TensorFlow Lite model.
So the process of
converting means
it's going to shrink the model.
It's going to optimize the model
for running on small devices,
for running on devices
where battery life is
a concern, and things like that.
So out of that process, I
get a TensorFlow Lite model,
which I can then run
on different devices.
And here's the code
to actually do that.
So we've got a little
bit of a breaking change
between TensorFlow
1 and TensorFlow 2.
So in the workbook that
was on that QR code,
I've put both pieces of code on
how to create the SavedModel.
And then once you've done that,
the third line from the bottom
here is the TF Lite Converter.
And all you have
to do is say here's
the SavedModel directory.
Run the TF Lite Converter from
SavedModel in that directory,
and it will generate
a .tflite file for me.
And that .tflite file is what
I can then use on mobile.
So let's take a look
at that in action,
if we can switch
back to the laptop.
So all I'm going to do
within the same workbook
is I'm going to run that
code that I just saw.
And I'm using TensorFlow
1.x and Colab here.
And we shall see
that it actually
has saved out a model
for me in this directory.
And I need that in the
next piece of code,
because I have to tell it the
directory that it got saved to.
So I'll just paste that in,
and then I'll run this out.
And we can see the TF
Lite Converter is what
will do the conversion for us.
So if I run that, it
gives me the number 612.
Can anybody guess why it
gives me the number 612?
It's not an HTTP code.
I thought it was
that, at first, too.
That's actually just
the size of the model.
So the model that I just trained
off those six pieces of data,
when that got compiled
down, it's a 612 byte model.
So if I go in there,
you can see I saved it
in /tmp/model.tflite.
And if in my Colab, if I go
and I look at /tmp directory,
we'll see model.tflite is there.
And I could download that
then to start using it
in my mobile apps if I like.
Can we switch back to
the slides, please?
So now, we have the model.
We've trained the model.
Obviously, the models
you're going to train
are hopefully a little bit
more complicated than the one
that I did.
You've been able to convert
that model to TF Lite.
And now, what can you
do with that model,
particularly on mobile?
Well, there's three sets of
options that I want to cover.
The first one, if you were
at the developer keynote,
you probably saw ML Kit.
And ML Kit is super cool.
For me, in particular, it uses
the Firebase programming API.
Any Firebase fans, here?
Yeah, woo!
The Firebase API
for programming,
I find particularly cool.
It's got a really
nice asynchronous API.
And when you think about
it, when I'm using a model,
I'm going to be passing
data to the model.
The model is going to
run some inference,
and it's going to send
something back to me.
So it's perfect for
Firebase, and it's
perfect for that asynchronous
API that Firebase gives us.
If we don't want to use
Firebase-- and remember,
Firebase ships with a bunch
of models that work out
of the box for vision detection
and some of the AutoML
stuff that we saw today.
But you can also ship
your custom TF Lite model
into Firebase if you want.
But if you don't want to use
Firebase, or maybe your model
is going to be deployed in a
country where Firebase isn't
supported, or you want it
to work completely offline,
and things like that, then the
idea is you can still deploy
a model directly to your app.
And I'm going to show a
TensorFlow Lite for that,
and getting low level, and
using TensorFlow Lite directly
instead of going through
the ML Kit wrapper.
And then finally, there's
the mobile browser.
So you can actually
deploy a model.
You can convert it
to JSON, and you
can deploy it to run, actually,
in a mobile browser, which
I find pretty cool.
So first, let's take
a look at ML Kit.
So ML Kit is Google's solution
for Firebase developers
and for mobile
developers who want
to have machine learning models
running in their applications.
Any ML Kit users
here, out of interest?
Oh, not many.
Wow.
Well, you're in for a treat
if you haven't used it yet.
Go check out the Firebase
booth, the Firebase sandbox.
They got some really cool
stuff that you can play with.
But just to show how
it works, the idea
is that in the Firebase
console, you can either
pick one of the preexisting
models that Firebase gives you,
or you can upload the model
that you just created.
So in Firebase,
you've got the option
to say a custom model
I've uploaded-- here,
you can see one that I
did a couple of weeks ago
of this model that I uploaded.
It's now in the
Firebase console,
and I can use it
within my Firebase app.
And I can use it alongside a lot
of the other Firebase goodies
like analytics.
Or a really cool
one is A/B testing.
So I can have two
versions of my model.
I could A/B test to
see which works best.
Those kind of services
are available to Firebase
developers, and when integrated
with machine learning,
I find that makes
it pretty cool.
And then once I've
done that, now,
when I start building
my application,
I do get all of the goodness of
the Firebase programming API.
So if this is on Android, the
idea is with TensorFlow Lite,
there's a TensorFlow
Lite runtime
object that we'll often
call the interpreter.
And here, you can see, I'm
just calling interpreter.run.
I'm passing it my inputs.
So in this case, if it's
Fahrenheit to centigrade
conversion, I'm just
going to pass it a float.
And then in its
onSuccessListener,
it's going to give me a
call back when the model has
finished executing.
So it's really nice
in the sense that it
can be very asynchronous.
If you have a really
big model that
might take a long time to
run, instead of you locking up
your UI thread, it's going to be
working nice and asynchronously
through ML Kit.
So in my addOnSuccessListener,
I'm adding a SuccessListener.
It's going to give me a
call back with the results.
And then that
result, I can parse
to get my output from
the machine learn model.
And it's really
as simple as that.
And in this case, I'm
passing it in a float.
It's converting the temperature.
It's sending a float back to me.
And that's why my getOutput
array is a float array
with a single element in it.
That's one thing if you haven't
worked in machine learning
and if you haven't built machine
learning models before, one
of the things that
you'll encounter a lot
is that when you're
passing data in,
you pass data in as tensors.
But when you are mapping
those tensors to a high level
programming language,
like Java or Kotlin,
you tend to use arrays.
And when it's passing
stuff back to you,
it's passing back a tensor.
And again, they tend
to map to arrays,
and that's why in the code
here, you're seeing arrays.
So iOS.
Any iOS fans, here?
Oh, a few.
Hey, nobody booed.
You said they would boo.
[CHUCKLING]
So in iOS, it also works.
So for example, again, I
have my interpreter in iOS.
This is Swift code.
I'll call the .run
method on my interpreter.
I'll pass it the inputs, and
I will get the outputs back.
And again, in this
very simple model,
I'm just getting a
single value back.
So it's just my outputs at
index 0 I'm going to read.
If you're doing
something more complex,
your data in and your
data out structures
are going to be a bit
more complex than this.
But as Daniel
mentioned earlier on,
we have a bunch of
sample applications
that you can dissect to take
a look at how they actually
do it.
So that's ML Kit.
And that's a rough
look at how it
can work with the custom
models that you build
and convert to run
in TensorFlow Lite.
But let's take a look at the
TensorFlow Lite runtime itself.
So now, if I'm building
an Android application,
and I've built my
model, and I don't
want to depend on an exterior
service like the Firebase
service to deploy
the model for me,
I want to bundle the
model with my app.
And then, however, the user
gets the app, via the Play Store
or via other means, the
model is a part of that.
Then it's very easy
for me to do that.
So that .tflite file that I
created earlier on, all I have
to do is put that in my assets
folder in Android as an asset,
just like any other-- like
any image, or any JPEG,
or any of those kind of things.
It's just an asset.
But the one thing
that's really important,
and it's the number one
bug that most people will
hit when they first
start doing this,
is that when Android deploys
your app to the device
to run it, it will zip up.
It will compress everything
in the Assets folder.
The model will not work
if it is compressed.
It has to be uncompressed.
So when you build out Gradle,
you just specify aaptOptions.
You say noCompress
"tflite", and then it
won't compress the
tflite file for you.
And then you'll be able to
run it and do inference.
So many times, I've worked with
people building their first TF
Lite application, it
failed unloading it
into the interpreter.
They had no idea why.
And it's they've forgotten
to put this line.
So if you only take one
thing away from this talk,
take this slide
away, because it will
solve a lot of
your problems when
you get started with TF Lite.
Then of course, still
in build.gradle,
all you have to do is,
in your dependencies,
you add the implementation of
the TensorFlow-lite runtime.
And what that's
going to do is it's
going to give you the latest
version of TensorFlow Lite,
and then that will give you
the interpreter that you
can use it.
And this QR code is a link.
I've put the full
app that I'm going
to show in a moment on GitHub,
so you can go and have a play
and hack around
with it if you like.
So now, if I want to
actually do inference--
so this is Kotlin code.
And there's a few things
to take a look at here
on how you'll do inference
and how you'll actually
be able to get your model up
and running to begin with.
So first of all, there are two
things that I'm declaring here.
Remember earlier, we tend
to use the term interpreter
for the TF Lite runtime.
So I'm creating a TF
Lite object, which
I'm going to call interpreter.
Sorry, I'm going to create
an interpreter object, which
I'm going to call TF Lite.
And then I'm going to create a
MappedByteBuffer object, which
is the TF Lite model.
Now earlier, remember, I
said you put the TF Lite
model into your Assets folder.
How you read it out
of the Assets folder
is as a MappedByteBuffer.
I'm not going to show the
code for that in the slides,
but it's available
on the download,
if you want have a look
at it for yourself.
And then you're also going to
need a TF Lite Options object.
And that TF Lite
Options object is
used to set things like
the number of threads
that you wanted to execute on.
So now, to
instantiate your model
so that you can start using
it, it's as easy as this.
So first of all, I'm going to
call a loadModelfile function.
That loadModelfile
function is what
reads the TF Lite model
out of the Assets folder
as a MappedByteBuffer.
And it gives me my
MappedByteBuffer
called tflitemodel.
In my options, I'm going
to say, for example,
I just want this to
run on one thread.
And then when I instantiate
my interpreter like this,
by giving it that
MappedByteBuffer of the model
and giving it the options,
I now have an interpreter
that I can run inference
on in Android itself.
And what does the
inference look like?
It will look
something like this.
So remember earlier,
when I mentioned
a neural network takes in a
number of inputs as tensors,
it gives you a number
of outputs as tensors.
Those tensors, in a higher level
language like Kotlin or Java
or Swift, will map to arrays.
So even though I'm
feeding in a single float,
I have to feed that
in as an array.
So that's why here,
my input value
is a float array with
a single value in it.
So if I want to convert
100, for example,
that's going to be a float array
with a single value containing
100.
And that F is for float,
not for Fahrenheit.
When I was rehearsing
these slides before,
somebody was like, oh,
how'd you put Fahrenheit
into code like that.
But it's a float.
It's not Fahrenheit.
And then when I'm
reading, we have
to get down a little
low level here,
because the model's going to
send me out a stream of bytes.
I know that those bytes map to
a float, but Kotlin doesn't.
Java doesn't.
So those stream of bytes, I
know they're mapping to a float.
And a float has 4 bytes, so I'm
going to create a byte buffer.
I'm going to allocate 4
bytes to that byte buffer,
and I'm just going to set
its order to be native order.
Because there's
different orders like
big-endian and little-endian.
But when you're using TF Lite,
always just use native order.
And then to do my inference,
I call tflite.run.
I give it my input value.
I give it my output value.
It'll read from the input value.
It'll write to the output file.
And then on the output file,
if I want to get my prediction,
it's written those 4 bytes.
I have to rewind them, and
then I'm going to read a float.
And what Kotlin will
do is say, OK, I'm
taking those 4 bytes
out of that buffer.
And I'm going to give you
back a float from them.
So that's how I would
do an inference.
It seems very complex for a
very simple task, like float in,
float out, but the structure
is the same regardless
of how complex your input is
and how complex your output is.
So while this might seem to be
the 20 pound hammer for the one
pound nail, it's
also the same hammer
when you have a 20 pound nail.
So that was Android,
iOS is very similar.
So in iOS, all I have to do is I
put my model in my application.
So I just put my TF Lite model.
It's an asset like any other.
And then in code, first
of all, I create a pod.
And in my pod file, I'll have
a pod for TensorFlow Lite.
I've spoken at I/O for
the last five years,
and this is my first time
ever showing C++ code.
I'm kind of geeking
out a little bit.
Right now, it supports
objective C++.
We do have a Swift wrapper
in some of our sample
applications, but the
Swift wrapper, right now,
only works in a few scenarios.
We're working at
generalizing that.
So for now, I'm just
going to show C++ code.
Any C++ fans, here?
Oh, wow.
More than I thought.
Nice.
So then your C++ code, it's
exactly the same model as I was
just showing.
So first of all, I'm going
to create an interpreter,
and I'm going to call
that interpreter.
And now, I'm going to
create two buffers.
So these are buffers
of unsigned ints.
One buffer is my input
buffer that I call ibuffer.
The other buffer is my output
buffer that I call obuffer.
And both of these,
the interpreter,
I'm just going to say, hey,
use a typed_tensor for these.
So that's my input.
That's my output.
And when I tflite.run, it's
going to read from the input,
write to the output.
Now, I have an output buffer,
and I can just get my inference
back from that output buffer.
So that was a quick
tour of TF Lite, how
you can build your model,
save it as a TF Lite,
and I forgot to show--
oh, no.
I did show, sorry, where you can
actually download as a TF Lite.
But I can demo it now
running an Android.
So if we can switch
back to the laptop?
So I'm going to go
to Android Studio.
And I've tried to make
the font big enough.
We can all see the font.
And let me just scroll
that down a little bit.
So this was the Kotlin code
that I showed a moment ago,
and the simplest possible
application that I could build
is this one.
So it's a simple
Android application.
It's got one button on it.
That button says do inference.
When you push that,
it's hard code.
It'll pass 100 to the
model and get back
the response for the model.
I have it in debug mode.
I have some breakpoints set.
So let's take a look
at what happens.
So once I click Do Inference,
I'm hitting this breakpoint now
in Android Studio.
And I've set up
my input inputVal,
and we can see my inputVal
is containing just 100.
And if I step over, my
outputVal has been set up.
It's a direct byte buffer.
Right now, position is 0.
Its capacity is 4.
I'm going to set its
order, and then I'm
going to pass the
inputVal containing
100, the outputVal,
which is my empty 4 byte
buffer, to tflite.run.
Execute that, and the TF Lite
interpreter has done its job,
and it's written
back to my outputVal.
But I can't read that yet.
Remember earlier,
the position was 1.
The limit was 4.
The capacity was 4.
It's written to it, now.
So that buffer is full.
So when I rewind,
now, we can see
my position has gone back to 0.
So I know I can start
reading from that buffer.
So I'm going to say
outputVal.getFloat,
and we'll see the prediction
that comes back is that 211.31.
So that model has been wrapped
by the TF Lite runtime.
I've given it the input buffer.
I've given that
the output buffer.
I've executed it, and it's
given me back that code.
And actually, there's one
really cool Kotlin language
feature that I want
to demonstrate, here.
I don't know if anybody
has seen this before.
This might be the first
time we've actually
ever shown this on stage.
But if I want to run
this model again,
you'll notice that there
are line numbers here.
All I have to do
is type goto 50.
I'm seeing who's still awake.
Of course, it's gosub 50.
So that's just a very
quick and very simple
example of how this
would run in Android.
And again, that
sample is online.
It's on GitHub.
I've put it on GitHub so that
we can have a play with it.
All right, if we can
switch back to the slides?
So the third of the options
that I had mentioned-- first
was ML Kit.
Second was to TF Lite.
The third of the
options was then
to be able to use JavaScript
and to be able to run
your model in a browser.
So TensorFlow.js is your friend.
So the idea is that
with TensorFlow.js,
in your Python, when
you're building the model,
you've PIP installed a
library called TensorFlow.js.
And then that
gives you a command
called TensorFlow.js converter.
With TensorFlow.js
converter, if you'd
saved that as a saved model,
as we showed earlier on,
you just say, hey, my input
format's a SavedModel.
Here's the directory
the SavedModel is in.
Here's the directory I
want you to write it to.
So now, once it's
done that, it's
actually going to
take that SavedModel
and convert that
into a JSON object.
So now, in a super, super simple
web page-- and this QR code,
again, has that web page--
now, all I have to
do is say, here's
the URL of that model.json.
And I will say const model
= await tf.loadLayersModel,
giving it that URL.
So if you're using
TensorFlow.js in your browser
with that script tag right
at the top of the page, now,
that model is loaded from
a JSON serialization.
And I can start
running inference
on that model in the browser.
So here was how I would use it.
Again, I'm setting up my inputs.
And JavaScript,
you know earlier,
I was saying you're
going to pass in arrays,
and you get out arrays, except
in a high level language?
Sorry, you pass in tensors.
You get out tensors.
High level language tends
to wrap them in arrays.
TensorFlow.js actually gives
you a tensor 2D object,
and that's what I'm using here.
So the tensor 2D object
takes two parameters.
The first parameter is the
array that you want to pass in,
and you can see here that
array is just the value 10.
It's a single item array.
And then the second parameter
is the shape of that array.
So here, the first
parameter is a 10.
The second parameter is 1, 1.
And that's the
shape of that array.
It's just a 1 by 1 array.
So once I've done that,
and I have my input, now,
if I want to run inference using
the model, all I have to do
is say model.predictinput.
And it will give
me back my results.
In this case, I was
alerting the results.
But in my demo, I'm
actually going to write it.
So if we can switch
back to the demo box?
And I have that super simple
web page hosted on the web.
And I've put that model in
there, and it's going to run.
This is a slightly
different model.
I'll show training
that model in a moment.
This was just the model
where y equals 2x minus 1.
So I'm doing an inference
where x equals 10.
And if x equals 10, y equals
2x minus 1 will give you 19.
And when I train the model
on six items of data,
it says 18.97.
So again, all I do is, in
Python, I can train the model.
With TensorFlow.js, I can
then convert that model
to a JSON object.
And then in TensorFlow.js, I
can instantiate a model off
of that JSON and then
start doing predictions
in that model.
If we can switch back to the
demo machine for a moment?
Oh, no.
I'm still on the demo
machine, aren't I?
I can show that in
action in a notebook.
I lost my notebook.
So this notebook
is also available,
where I gave those QR codes.
And this notebook, again,
is a very similar one
to the one I showed earlier
on super, super simple neural
network, single layer
with a single neuron.
I'm not going to step
through all of it now.
But the idea is if you PIP
install TensorFlow.js right now
in Google Colab, it will upgrade
Google Colab from TensorFlow
1.13 to TensorFlow 2.
So if you run through
this and install that,
you'll see that happening.
And then once you have
TensorFlow 2 on your machine,
then you can use the
TensorFlow.js converter,
as shown here, giving
it the input format
and giving it the SavedModel
from the directory
as I'd done earlier on.
And it will write
out to /temp/linear.
The one thing to
take note of, though,
if you are doing this yourself
is that when it writes to that,
it won't just write
the JSON file.
It also writes a binary file.
So when you upload the JSON
file to the web server--
to be able to create a model
off of that JSON file, make sure
the binary file is in the same
directory as the JSON file.
Or the model off
of the JSON file
is going to give you some
really weird results.
That's also the number one
bug that I found when people
have been using TensorFlow.js.
It's that they will
convert to the JSON file.
They'll upload it
to their server.
They'll have no idea what
that random binary file was,
and they're getting
indeterminate results back
from that model.
So make sure when you do
that, you get that model.
I don't know if I have one
here that I prepared earlier
that I can show you
what it looks like.
I don't.
It's empty, right now.
But when you run this
and you write it out,
you'll see that the model.json
and a binary file are there.
Make sure you upload
both of them to use it.
Can we switch back to
the slides, please?
So that was a quick
summary, where
we saw that model that you build
using Python can be converted
to TensorFlow Lite.
You can save it as a SavedModel.
You can convert it to TensorFlow
Lite and use it in ML Kit,
or use it directly in
TensorFlow Lite itself.
Alternatively, if you
want to convert it to .js,
then it will save it
out as a JSON file.
You can convert
it to a JSON file
and then use that in JavaScript.
So that's the summary
of being able to use
those models on mobile devices.
But now, Daniel is
going to tell us
all about going beyond
phones and the web.
So thank you, Daniel.
Thank you.
DANIEL SITUNAYAKE:
Thank you, Laurence.
[APPLAUSE]
Awesome.
So like Lawrence says so far,
we've talked about phones.
But these aren't the only
devices that we use every day.
So I'm going to talk
about some new tools
that our team has designed to
help developers use machine
learning everywhere.
So our homes and
cities are filled
with devices that contain
embedded computing power.
And in fact, every year,
literally billions of devices
are manufactured that contain
small but highly capable
computation devices
called microcontrollers.
So microcontrollers
are at the core
of most of our digital
gadgets, everything
from the buttons
on your microwave
through to the electronics
controlling your car.
And our team
started to ask, what
if developers could
deploy machine learning
to all of these objects?
So at the TensorFlow
Dev Summit, we
announced an
experimental interpreter
that will run TensorFlow
models on microcontrollers.
So this is actually a
new frontier for AI.
We have super cheap hardware
with super huge battery life
and no need for an
internet connection,
because we're doing
offline inference.
So this enables some incredible
potential applications,
where AI can become truly
personal while still preserving
privacy.
We want to make it ridiculously
easy for developers
to build these new
types of products,
so we've actually
worked with SparkFun
to design a
microcontroller development
board that you can buy today.
It's called the
SparkFun Edge, and it's
powered by an ultra efficient
ARM processor that's packed
with sensors and I/O ports.
So you can use it to prototype
embedded machine learning code.
And we have example
code available
that shows how you can
run speech recognition
in a model that takes up less
than 20 kilobytes of memory,
which is crazy.
So I'm now going to give you
a quick demo of the device,
and I'll show you
what some of this code
looks like for
running inference.
So you should remember before
we do this, all of this
is all available on our website,
along with documentation
and tutorials.
And the really cool thing,
while you're here at I/O,
you should head over
to the Codelabs area.
And you can try
hands on development
with the SparkFun Edge boards.
So let's switch over
to the camera, here.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I think
that actual image was bigger
than 20 kilobytes.
DANIEL SITUNAYAKE:
Yeah, definitely.
It's kind of
mind-blowing that you
can fit a speech model into
such a small amount of memory.
So this is the device itself.
So it's just a little dev board.
I'm going to slide
the battery in.
So the program we
have here, basically,
is just running inference.
And every second of
audio that comes in,
it's running through a
little model that looks
for a couple of hot words.
You can see this
light is flashing.
It flashes once every
time inference is run.
So we're getting a pretty
decent frame right,
even though it's a tiny,
low powered microcontroller
with a coin cell battery.
So what I'm going to do now
is take my life in my hands
and try and get it to
trigger with the hot words.
And hopefully, you'll
see some lights flash.
Yes, yes, yes.
First time, not lucky.
So it's not working so great
when we've got the AC going,
but you saw the lights
lighting up there.
And I basically got a
really simple program
that looks at the
confidence score
that we get from the model
that the word yes was detected.
And the higher the confidence,
the more lights appear.
So we got three lights there.
So it's pretty good.
Let's have a look at the code.
So if we can go
back to the slides?
So all we do, basically,
to make this work is
we've got our model, which is
just a plain old TensorFlow
Lite model that you trained
however you wanted to
with the rest of our
TensorFlow tool chain.
And we have this model
available as an array
of bytes within our app.
We're going to pull
in some objects
that we're going to use
to run the interpreters.
So first of all, we
create a resolver,
which is able to pull
in the TensorFlow ops
that we need to run the model.
We then create some
memory that is allocated
for some of the
working processes that
are going to happen
as we input data
and run some of the operations.
And then we build and
interpret the object,
which we pass all
this stuff into,
that is actually going to
execute the model for us.
So the next thing
we do is basically
generate some
features that we're
going to pass into the model.
So we have some
code not pictured
here, which takes audio
from the microphones that
are on the board and transforms
that into a spectrogram
that we then feed
into the model.
Once we have done that,
we invoke the model,
and we get an output.
So the output is
just another tensor,
and we can look
through that tensor
to find which of our classes
were able to be matched.
And hopefully, in
this case, it was
the yes that showed up as
the highest probability.
So all of this code
is available online.
We have documentation
that walks you through it.
And like I said, the device
is available here, in I/O,
in the Codelabs labs area, if
you'd like to try it yourself.
So tiny computers are great,
but sometimes, you just
need more power.
So imagine you have a
manufacturing plant that
is using computer vision to spot
faulty parts on a fast moving
production line.
So we recently announced
the Coral platform,
which provides hardware
for accelerated
inference at the Edge.
So these are small
devices still,
but they use something
called the Edge
TPU to run machine learning
models incredibly fast.
So one of our
development boards here
can run image classification
on several simultaneous video
streams at 60 frames per second.
So it's super awesome.
We have these devices
available to check out
in the Codelabs area, as well.
And in addition, in
the ML and AI sandbox,
there's a demo of
showing a use case,
spotting faulty parts
in manufacturing.
So once again, it's super easy
to run TensorFlow Lite models
on Coral devices.
And this example shows
how you can load a model,
grab camera input, run
inference, and annotate
an output image in just
a few lines of code.
So all of this,
again, is available
online on the Coral site.
So we've shown a ton of exciting
stuff today, and all of it
is available on TensorFlow.org
and the Coral site, right now.
So you'll be able to find
example code, example apps,
pretrained models,
and everything
you need to get started
with deploying to device.
And I've got some
links up here for you.
But while you're
here at I/O, there
are a ton of other opportunities
to play with on device ML.
So we have a couple of sessions
that I'd like to call out,
here.
We have the TensorFlow Lite
official talk, tomorrow,
which is going to go into a lot
more depth around TensorFlow
Lite and the tools we have
available for on device
inference and converting models.
And we also have
a talk on What's
New in Android ML, which
is this evening at 6:00 PM.
So you should definitely
check both of those out.
And in the Codelabs area,
we have a load of content.
So if you're just
learning TensorFlow,
we have a six part course you
can take to basically go end
to end from nothing to knowing
what you're talking about.
And then we have a
couple of Codelabs
you can use for on
device ML, and I
think there's a Coral
codelab, as well.
So thank you so
much for showing up.
And I hope this
has been exciting,
and you've got a glimpse of
how you can do on device ML.
Like you saw in the
keynote, there's
some amazing applications,
and it's up to you
to build this
amazing, new future.
So thank you so
much for being here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]